increasing numbers of protesters are
transitioning from standoffs on the
streets
to military and weapons training in the
jungle fronted by some of the ethnic
armies that have been fighting myanmar's
security forces
for decades last month in the city of
bago north of yangon
protesters faced one of the deadliest
crackdowns by security forces
more than 80 people were killed this
activist from bago was there
he was shot while on the streets
protesting he does not want to be
identified
he said the security forces were using
rocket-propelled grenades
after that day he and nine other
activists wanted to do more
so they left to train with one of the
korean ethnic armies
i've seen the ethnic current army fight
with myanmar's army on social media
i saw the current groups fighting
together against the army
i'm grateful for everybody that supports
each other in the crisis right now
i want democracy to return to myanmar
and that fighting has intensified in the
korean-controlled areas since the coup
in february
sending civilians fleeing for their
lives into hiding
eighteen-year-old dog guy lore is ethnic
corrine
and she has witnessed the fighting
between the rebels and the myanmar army
since she was a girl she started
training after finishing high school
initially refusing to learn how to use
firearms
but that changed once she saw the
attacks on her people
i come out with that i want to help
people and i want to have freedom in our
lives
i don't want the jinta taking advantage
of the people that's the reason why the
burmese protesters are coming to our
camp to receive training
the majority bamar ethnic group
historically has not become involved
with the ethnic rebel armies
that's changing so what you have is the
ethnic palma and the ethnic minorities
coming together
to fight against a common enemy which is
a military that is running amok
and this extends also uh to the youth
uh the gen zed youth in in in places
like mandalay and yangon
now have common cause with the ethnic
youth whether it be the koran or the
kachin or the karenia the mon youth
even though the two groups have
different views and experiences in
fighting the army
at the end of the months-long training
they're drawn closer together in what
appears to be
a growing and more unified front against
the junta's forces
scott heidler al jazeera